o pessoal nos pensamentos feliz tá aqui
ó poder participar de um evento como
esse é de rolar que apague para falar
dos temas que eu tenho visto sobre
inovação sobre tecnologia e mega
tendências com o jogo consigo entender
plenamente a dor do músico como quando
ele tem que entrar no palco tem que
fazer uma seleção muito cuidadosa no set
list ator músico é deixar de fora
algumas músicas que ele compôs com tanto
carinho do amigo ted nos traz é
selecionar e sistemas causar impacto em
menos de dois minutos para sair não é
com muito carinho que nós vamos falar
esse tempo o propósito massivo do ted é
fazer o quê
espalhar a ideia de transformar o poder
tocar as pessoas para que essas pessoas
possam sair daqui de ser protagonista 10
a 12 nós queremos um salto muito feliz
aqui com vocês imaginam uma dessas
idéias podem colocar o seguinte ao
conhecer o nosso papel como isso a nosso
favor enquanto pessoas e como
profissionais muito restituição não
coloca essa pergunta a tecnologia tem
evoluído no mesmo exponencial
absolutamente show meta é nosso lar que
não não evoluir nessa velocidade do
nosso mais sete lagoas e as novidades
nós temos visto uma transformação
tecnológica como nunca aconteceu
a conexão de dispositivos maiorzinho big
data nós temos visto inúmeras
tecnologias surge a pergunta que fica é
começa a surgir um certo e se nas
pessoas a pergunta é qual vai ser o
nosso papel em um mundo que evoluíram
anunciar as cápsulas correspondente a
essa pergunta que eu coloco pra nossa
conversa
londres - a mudança como passa hoje ele
é de base tecnológica mudança é de base
tecnológica galera se conectado em
grande medida a 96 e 98 quando nós temos
o boom da internet no mundo
então as máquinas já evoluiu de forma
exponencial
integração da tecnologia se tornou
transversal então essa tecnologia começa
a impactar todos os negócios que eu falo
muito é tão existe mais empresas que não
sejam ipi todas as empresas têm alguma
menina aqui um sol sendo se você tirar
os sistemas de tecnologia das empresas
relação da gente para uma transformação
de base tecnológica e com essa mudança a
tecnologia nós temos novos modelos de
negócios novas formas de criar e
distribuir valores com as gravações e
por fim nós temos um impacto cada vez
maior das empresas e nas pessoas que
normalmente sozinho totais em barcos
justamente no fim dessa cadeia por isso
é importante discutir tecnologia no
começo a entender que ela é de base
tecnológica
mas no fim ela nos impacta diariamente a
mudança quando chega aos 17 pontos o ser
humano que não sabia da existência
acreditar na mudança com o veloz mas
sempre aconteceu
o exemplo que eu trago aqui um
palestrante chamado observa que fala o
seguinte essa cota de nova iorque 1930
avenida nós vemos um evento muito
curioso nessa volta da mesa
nós temos toda a gente e carinhosas de
um carro
questionada se essa é uma tendência que
veio para ficar e naturalmente as
pessoas responderam a uma agressão de
final
essa é uma tendência muito caro não é
confiável e não sabemos se isso será
mesmo a quinta 29
treze anos depois o seguinte tem apenas
uma personagem carroça então que a
tecnologia causa aquilo que é
extravagante tudo é muito estranho o
momento
logo depois é é aceite por toda a
população e as mudanças têm acontecido
acontecendo
elas acontecem semana os clientes
falarem dias
então esse é um componente muito
importante mudança pra vocês aqui com a
imagem da empresa
08 08
4 essa notícia publicada aqui no brasil
falando o seguinte chega uma das
primeiras impressões perder 30 dólares
para produtor de página imagem que na
nossa cabeça que isso não vai demorar
muito vai demorar décadas para isso
acontecer pelo menos oito anos nos
deparamos com isso como um avião no
último ano em 2016
ans onze peças da turbina são bento
pessoa desde então é esse tipo de
mudança que eu digo você sai de um
protótipo de algo que parece algo pra
gente fazer algo muito falado pra
academia e bloco depois vai bater na
sociedade
em 2006 para estas peças de avião ao
defender isso muda toda a cadeia
logística mudar a forma como nós fazemos
negócios pessoal do computador de uma
maior capacidade computacional que
apenas o governo americano tinha acesso
2006 nós chegamos em 2016
e essa mesma capacidade computacional
para a placa de vídeo que vai dentro do
nosso computador
o movimento que traz que começa a
acontecer é muito relevante aqui
ou seja aqui uma superpotência detinha
10 anos depois os indivíduos
nós estamos vivendo na era mais incrível
para quem quer inovar para quem quer
empreender para quem quer fazer isso
nunca foi tão barato ser dono do seu
destino quinta foi tão democrático tão
acessível podemos dar um melhor
tecnologia tem essa componente de
democratização que ora simplesmente
fascinante estamos na época o nosso
temos mais capacidade justamente mudar
nossa realidade
12 anos
empresas que chegaram a um pião muito
fácil de lembrar que nós temos em 2009
em casa em 2010 envolvendo três carros
por volta de três casos dois anos o
ritmo exponencial e aumento empresas
startup soluções de base tecnológica que
no mundo não só nos últimos dois anos
então
através da nossa história está fazendo
os últimos temas hoje eu viajo o brasil
criado mundo tem que entender só também
16% mais 300 cidades discutindo e
sistemas de inovação e tecnologia que
compartilha algumas histórias com vocês
a primeira história assim no chile e no
ano passado eu falar sobre mapeamento do
genoma é humano que em 2003 pela
primeira vez uma pessoa teve com o seu
genoma mapeado no impacto de 4 embate
com a mente toda a sua constituição
física tenha propensão você desenvolver
determinados tipos de doença ao longo da
vida em 2003 com o filme sobre genético
custava mais de 3 bilhões de dólares uma
coisa absolutamente inacessível e nessa
oportunidade em abril do ano passado
o palestrante foi o seguinte caminho
para menores
todo mundo ficou muito impressionado com
aquilo que isso poderia custar 10 mil
dólares saber o que vai acontecer para
sua saúde ao longo do tempo todo com
maravilhado
ele falou o seguinte se eu te contar
agora existe uma startup chamada tudo
feminino dos estados unidos que parece
tese por 200 dólares 200 dólares ao
estava 3 bilhões de dólares
eu fiquei intrigado com aquilo ele falou
que só é feito nos estados unidos estava
em prova uma semana depois na hora eu
pego o celular me inscrevendo da
secitece e não é um dólar se tivessem
caído quase de manhã o site recomenda se
digitar o cep de onde eu estava me
dirigisse até uma farmácia uma pegadinha
aspirina e dor de cabeça
eu cheguei me sentindo um pouco perdido
na formação foi eu vim fazer um
mapeamento genético dos jetsons tamanho
[Música]
dessa marca indica
no segundo semestre desse ano seguinte o
seu material genético para isso está a
caminho da carolina do norte em quatro
semanas vai receber 100 por cento
resultado de um mapeamento duas coisas
ou em curitiba passando pelo shopping eu
recebi um e mail de dia seguinte tudo o
que ela vê um 50% do seu genoma e
provavelmente neste momento nos causando
anos
sinto medo pavor da criança chora se
alguma câmera de fumando junto ao núcleo
de prática meu viação característica de
excelente genética do teste que emitem o
teste que por exemplo eu tenho 840 por
cento de chance de desenvolver câncer de
pulmão mais do que a população agora
disso patelar negativa de tabagismo como
é que eu quero chegar pessoal político
da velocidade da transformação dos
nossos avós morreram de doenças que eles
não sabiam que eram os nossos pais
eventualmente morrem ou morrerão de
doenças que ele sabia se era contratar
nós estamos vendo no mundo da tecnologia
é tão poderosa três anos de antecedência
a doença chegando e poder ser prático
inflação nos testes então é um mundo
incrível só que o mundo vai se mudar só
eu queria compartilhar o seguinte
a mudança é tão veloz mesmo pessoas que
não vêm dando à idade como eu hoje em
ações dela
ano passado eu também estive no museu da
história da computação na verdade com
instrumentos muito precários de
computação cartões perfurados e de 50 e
60 sessões que óculos meus 31 anos
saberi foi usado em 20 sessões a partir
da oitava sessão eu começo a me preparar
os objetos que eu usei a oitava sessão
enquanto esquece que eu encontro
crianças pasma espalhando para aquele
objeto falando o que é isso
duas crianças do meu lado tirando o
celular para tirar uma foto de kerr
é um passo para trás para que ela não
soubesse que eu sabia o que era aquilo
só senhor já que ela era um poste como
dinossauro
nesse momento porque coisa porque ela
para tirar uma foto com ela quando nós
ficamos por exemplo nos salvar de um
software de edição de texto
nós sabemos que não esquece para ela
apenas naquele momento então mas não só
faz sentido perceba a trina que eu
conquistei um ano de descobrir o que faz
todo mundo que eu usei estava exposto no
museu essa velocidade com assombração de
mello
o segundo motivo a bola tirando a foto
que tudo aquilo era uma grande novidade
é a segunda vez que chamou dez anos
seguintes à venda duas sessões 10 acaba
então estava só na oitava sessão
e aí pessoal quando fala de tecnologia
como essa foto é o seguinte as pessoas
perguntam então tudo está na tecnologia
não aqui começa a segunda parte de uma
exposição que é uma inovação para ele se
o tecnologia falando do leixões
ele falou o seguinte olha só se você vai
a um restaurante do chef faz um prato
santástico a noite usando uma faca super
associada ao menos uma faca sua parcela
para cometer o crime
nos dois casos seja a preparação do
prato o brilhantismo o critério da
escala isso foi a razão não foi causado
pela faca mas sim uma pessoa então a
tecnologia não esqueçam
ela é mera ferramenta nesse contexto
todo ela instiga ela fascina mas no
final do dia na minha posição de
discutir quem está por trás dela ficou
alguns anos fazendo dela a tecnologia
exponencial possibilita mundo os
incríveis mas depende de como vamos
fazer isso o que nos leva ao próximo
ponto não pode nos fazer muito mais
tecnologia pode ser uma grande
na ação ela pode nos levar a ação ou nós
podemos passar horas mergulhados em
redes sociais
perdendo o nosso dinheiro então depende
muito do nosso enfoque
eu quero contar mais uma história da
tecnologia desde a perspectiva por
exemplo em pessoas se lamentando sobre
chegada tuber de outras tecnologias que
eu queria contar uma história pra fazer
em são paulo ano passado saiu de uma
reunião
perto das nações unidas um escritório de
uma empresa de tecnologia que o
empresário de deitos chamado no meio do
caminho nós começamos a discutir sobre o
resultado da reunião amanhã tinha sido
muito proveitosa e nós falávamos nós
vamos integrar essa ferramenta convidado
da vez um grande projeto e nesse momento
o motorista do governo começa a discutir
sobre mobilidade com a gente e falar
olha só a ferramenta
quem é essa pessoa que não fazia sentido
que ele vira pra gente muito charme uber
como uma mera alternativa esse momento
que vira pra gente entrar no carro
também falou o seguinte
isso aqui é uma história que eu tenho a
chance de ficar perto de empresas de
tecnologia que encontrar pessoas como
você que na verdade são pessoas como
vocês estão vendo aqui a perspectiva de
como nos anos a tecnologia para criar
oportunidades
criticando a história absolutamente
chegar a história de que além da
perspectiva e além de encarar uma
ferramenta a tecnologia como ferramenta
[Música]
como as pessoas que vão assumir o
protagonismo
a minha lógica mas gosta de mim foi a
seguinte é extremamente difícil chegar
de barco também um vôo até campinas de
coisa que o próprio trabalho coisa pra
porto velho e último trecho até ji
paraná tinha me falado pela som livre
de fato o ônibus que ela vai fazer então
como muitas das gerais e paraná
alcançado o objetivo é de treinamento
naquela sala com 121 pessoas mais
motivados - motivados pela pessoa mais
motivadas as chamava max durante dois
dias participando ativamente entregando
suor o tempo e ele querendo aprender
ao final do segundo dia de varzim
gostaria de jantar contínuo para
aprender mais
ele não chegou na janta a outra pessoa
como buscar até o hotel
eu perguntei por que essa pessoa me
falou que teve um pequeno problema
familiar é um pequeno problema foi a
estabilidade é um grande problema que
vai atrasar um dia resolvi fazer um
treinamento de uma fazenda já que o
marcos chega até lá
isso tudo claro mas eu vou aprendendo a
lidar com o fato de que meu filho não
queria estar nessa dimensão aprendendo
com isso fazendo treinamentos e tinha
todas as desculpas do mundo para não
falar
ele falou então me ajudar estar nessa
sala de aula me esforçando e aprendendo
tudo eu nunca perdi na minha vida uma
chance de aprender mais
o marcos foi um dos maiores apresentado
a minha vida os últimos tempos naquela
sala de outras pessoas que não estavam
aproveitando essa oportunidade então que
a tecnologia traz uma chance única de
embaixada mas no final do dia
a nossa adaptação da nossa vida
rolando o nosso nosso espaço eu acho que
provavelmente caminho exatamente o
contrário as máquinas estamos libertando
pra fazer coisas cada vez mais criativas
mais inteligência
mas nós temos muitos caras novas devem
estudar e aprender cada vez mais comum
estudamos as máquinas estão tomando
espaço mas nós estamos ocupando um
espaço que sempre foi dela fazer tarefas
repetitivas mas antes que não pertençam
dumont e agora vamos poder desenvolver
completamente nosso potencial
isso é só o começo essa geração nasceu
digital é uma segunda loja é essa
imagina 55% digital que vai se
aproveitar de um exponencial para
amplificar suas capacidades fazer cada
vez mais
por isso o pessoal nosso recado
temos que explorar a tecnologia para
desenvolver plenamente no nosso
potencial
o que quer desenvolver plenamente o
potencial face sentindo acção como ter
isso em parte do mundo não só vez mais
limpa só uma das duas cadeiras e uma
cadeira você vai tomar em uma hora ea
pessoa vai passar a outra cadeira é a
sua versão
aquilo que você poderia ter se tornado e
quando você poderia ter aprendido quando
você poder embarcar num cruzeiro do sul
no meu coração pra vocês
você senta na cadeira durante uma hora
em histórias incríveis para contar que
não encontra um personagem tão diferente
assim que vocês tenham sabedoria para
usar a tecnologia entendam que vocês vão
ser protagonistas não é incrível de
inovação mas que depende
fundamentalmente de vocês pra nós por
isso o pessoal que faz sobrar para o ser
humano mundo está com as bases policiais
vez se desenvolver o nosso lado humano e
criatividade inteligência e usar isso a
nosso favor então o pessoal desejo uma
casa na ilha quem pegou pra vocês que
vocês possam compartilhar pontos as
idéias
fico extremamente graves problemas com
alagamentos desde o fundo do meu coração
[Aplausos]